good morning i'm eddie wu welcome to
education live
today we're at fort street high school
and i'm going to be speaking with a
bunch of different people from all walks
of life
about how mathematics comes into contact
with their everyday
work and the things that they love and
that's why this morning i'm so delighted
to have the privilege
of speaking with olympic runner steve
solomon good day steve good night great
thank you so much for joining us video
element bump there appreciate that
thank you so much for joining us and
spending some time with us now
steve you and i even though people
wouldn't normally think of a math
teacher
an olympic runner having much in common
one of the things which i know
comes to me all the time is oh you must
have been into maths from you know since
you were really young
and that's how you became a math teacher
and i think people would assume the same
of an olympic runner
but you weren't always into running
right that's right you know um
i played all sports growing up eddie and
sports was something i just loved and
was passionate about you know i played
soccer cricket tennis rugby anything i
could
and it was only later in life in in high
school and and towards the later end of
high school that
athletics and running really came to to
be something that i enjoyed
grew a passion for and then was able to
turn into a career after school so it's
amazing
it sort of makes sense that you know say
for soccer soccer pitch is massive
you're doing a lot of running just in a
normal game right so you already have
that fitness and all that kind of thing
yeah
that's right you know everyone um knows
a little bit about my story of coming
really late into the sport so like while
i wasn't a runner growing up playing a
lot of sports i did a lot of running and
that all
kind of helped you know culminating to
helping me become the runner where
i've now enjoyed the last 10 years of
representing australia which has been
the greatest honor and privilege that's
amazing now steve we did want to talk a
bit about
math so i wanted to throw some numbers
at you but not just any numbers
numbers that do mean a lot to you so um
here's one that i understand is kind of
bittersweet for you it's a time actually
and that's four hundredths of a second
this is a time that
means a lot to you could you explain to
us the significance of it i can so four
hundredths of a second
is a number that i don't think i'll ever
forget
it was the number the amount of time
that i missed out on qualifying for the
rio olympic spy
and so yeah to rewind i i was able to
place eighth in the final of the olympic
games
in london as a 19 year old and then four
years later at the next olympics in rio
i was
coming back from a hamstring surgery
injury and
you know the way that we qualified for
the olympics at that point in time was
by time so we had to run a certain time
and that time was 45.4 seconds for 400
meters
and i crossed the line at this race uh
up north in in brisbane and on the clock
came up 45.2 seconds
when i crossed the line which is
fantastic that's lower than the 4540 i'd
qualified for the olympics
and then a couple of moments later that
time
disappeared on the board and 45 44
appeared wait a second so they'd already
registered you at 45.2
but then there was this why was there a
change in the time that was recorded for
your run now this is going to sound
crazy eddie but
you know we're moving at such speed that
the reason
that the clock showed 45 2 when i
crossed the line was actually my shadow
triggered
the clock to stop before my body which
is where they measure
the uh so of course your shadow's just a
teeny bit just that little bit in front
of me and we're talking about fractions
of a second
so because your actual time for your
body crossing was 45.44
which is not meaning that time and
that's why you had to miss out on the
2016 olympics so that's why i
i know that 400th of a second and it's
such a powerful number to me because it
was
uh what ultimately ended up being the
difference between
representing australia again at my
second olympics and watching it from my
home on the couch which i'm sure
is now a big motivator for you as you
head into the future and i guess that's
something i wanted to ask about
in terms of being a professional athlete
and you know continually
having training as part of your everyday
life like what role
does mathematics and numbers take in in
monitoring your own performance knowing
where you're at
could you give us a sense of how like
apart from times how do you keep
track of all that definitely we use just
a lot of numbers throughout
sport um you know one of the big numbers
that i use quite on a regular basis is
heart rate
so we do a lot of training and we
measure how fast our hearts beating and
typically the the kind of colloquial
measure of how fast can your heart beat
what's its maximum heart rate
is about 220 minus your age so that's
kind of what we we work off as
professional athletes and then
we work off percentages of that maximum
heart rate to tell if we're in different
training zones so heart rate's a big one
for me the other
uh modes of mass that we come into or
numbers that we care about
in athletics is blood lactate levels so
the story behind that is when you're
running really fast your body uses an
energy system called the lactic energy
energy system have you ever heard of
lactic acid maybe anything all right so
this is like what's building up in your
legs it's why like your legs burn and
they sort of feel like jelly right
after a point and because you run 400
meters so that's
enough time for that lactic build up to
really matter right so
how do you measure that so the lactic is
the limiting factor in the 400 it's why
at the end of the race you're so in so
much pain and your body can't contract
because it's just got so much lactic in
it so
what we do is they take a little prick
of blood from the ear
or one of your one of your fingers after
each rep and they can actually measure
how much lactic is in your blood at that
given point of time and the reason we do
that is because we try and get a sense
of
understanding and teaching the body that
it's okay to have all this byproducts in
our system it's okay
to kind of have all this lactic just
learn to relax through it so that's
another one that we keep a close eye on
one of the reasons why i was so excited
to speak with you steve is that um i
myself enjoy running i'm no athlete like
you uh but i guess that makes a lot of
sense of like when you're
you know you're at at pace and your
lungs are burning your whole body's sort
of screaming you're telling you stop
rest so you're talking about
trying to train yourself to actually
overcome that and become used to it is
that the idea that's exactly right you
know
running's hard you know we all know that
running is hard running 400 meters is
really hard
doing it really fast makes it even
harder and what we we see is the body
you know doesn't like hard things you
know typically when something's hard we
kind of shield away from it
but what we're really trying to do on
the athletic track is we're trying to
tell the body no it's okay we want to
continue to push through this
it's kind of like anything that we're
doing and we find hard if we were doing
push-ups
and you know we get to that point where
we don't want to do another push-up
we kind of it's the body's telling us
that we don't really want to do another
push-ups
we know that we can do it so we've got
to really force our way through it's the
same thing like i'm doing when i'm
running
at the later end of the races fantastic
yeah that is a very loud play
yeah um one of the things which um i
think we should just
sort of go on record and say it's a bad
idea if you are not an athlete to ever
compare yourself to an olympic of that
athlete
i really wanted to get a sense of you
know you mentioned before um
45 seconds roughly that it takes you to
run 400 meters so i thought
well i'd like to get a sense of this how
long would it take me
to run 400 meters so i gave it a go ran
around and oval
my time was 92 seconds which is more
than double
what it takes you so maybe if you're at
home and you've got get your runners on
give it a go see how you would compare
to steve but i thought to myself okay
400 meters roughly 45 seconds i'm trying
to understand
the maths of like how many steps you
take over that time like that's that's
cadence the rhythm at which you run
do you know how many strides you
normally take over the course of a race
absolutely it takes me about 170 strides
to cover the 400 meters 170 strides
400 meters okay so i'm trying to crunch
the numbers here right
now what that means is those 170 strides
over the 45 seconds if you take
if you go 400 meters that means every
second
you're traveling roughly 10 meters right
okay so i want to get a sense of this so
maybe if you can come over here with me
so 10 meters i mean my normal step's
about one meter
so if i count out one two three four
go further back i'm going to go for here
four five six
seven eight nine ten
so so steve where are you where i
started which is where you are
that's how far you go in
one second one second that's insane come
on back for a second because
i'm just thinking about your 170 strides
and you do that over 45
seconds so you're doing probably about
four strides across that distance
because yeah 170
divided by 45 about two and a half
meters for every single stride
i mean you're tall but that's crazy
right how do you feel like how does your
body feel as you're doing that
definitely you know it's something that
we teach the body to do it's not
something that i could
roll out of bed uh without training and
that's part of the reason why we train
so hard is to
allow the body to run at that speed and
to run at that cadence to move our legs
as quickly
as we need to be doing it at an olympic
level so it's it's a lot to do with the
training eddie
absolutely and you know you're talking
about heart rate before right um you
know
your max heart rate must be in the high
190s
is my guess what's your what's your
resting heart rate because your heart
must be so strong
that actually can powerfully pump blood
all the time do you know what that
difference is
definitely so at rest you know kind of
in the mornings when i'm waking up my
heart rate's around 41 beats per minute
41. that's so low i guess it's got that
that power there all the way
another loud plan okay now we've talked
a bit about um your past
um your your life as an athlete before
running and then you know what it's like
to be an athlete every day
one night look forward uh you missed out
on rio but you are
on track to head to the tokyo olympics
next year
and because they got postponed obviously
the coronavirus uh i think you've
mentioned um once that kind of shattered
your world
can you tell us what it's like to now be
on the road to prepare for those
olympics
definitely you know 2020 is some a year
that i've been thinking about
you know for the last four years you
know the the agony of missing the rio
olympic games
did ignite this motivation and this fire
in me
to make sure that i wasn't in that same
position that i was in 2016 and make
sure that i was
qualified safely comfortably and really
preparing to to win a medal at the tokyo
game so
for the last four years i've really been
training for this year knowing that this
was going to be the thing that i think
about
every day when i'm awake and even again
at night when i'm asleep
so with this year obviously the
coronavirus has meant that the olympics
has been postponed
what that really means for me is making
sure that the plan that i had for the
last three years
we can modify and tweak to make sure
that it's still relevant for the 12
months time when
the olympics will go ahead in 2021 so at
the moment i'm still training six days a
week eddie
i do three three to four running
sessions a week two to three gym
sessions a week a pilates session
a pool session a bike session a rowing
session so
we're training really hard at the moment
i'll tell you one nice thing about
training in the coronavirus period is
the pressure's off a little bit
you know one of the things about being a
professional athlete and competing so
often is
you're always being measured against
your very best time and you're always
being measured against the very best
other athletes in the world so
at the moment when there's no races
going on it is a chance for us to really
just focus on the training enjoy the
training have fun with the training
and make sure that we have the amount of
energy and motivation to continue us
through
for another year of brutal training
ahead of the tokyo games next year i
guess it is a bit of a silver lining
that you know
with the competitions a little bit sort
of on the low down now you can have that
focus on just you
as a running you kind of have to run
your own race right now
just to sort of begin to bring things to
a close you're the co-captain
of team australia you know i always love
sitting
in my living room and sort of standing
up as the race goes and getting to cheer
on
all the different athletes in every
different sport how can we at home be
supporting the team
in what they're achieving especially as
we head to tokyo it's a great question
you know
for the next 12 months or and even
further and especially at the games
all all support and communication is
just adored by us athletes so
there used to be a thing called telstra
hero messages where you could send
olympians a message
i'm not sure if that's still going to be
the case next year but we have now got
other ways to contact athletes there's
instagram there's twitter
there's facebook you know just just send
it send a dm send a good luck message it
means like such a world
uh to us athletes and then the other
thing that you can do is continue to
build on the legacy that we're able to
provide
at the time of the olympic games and
that's just enjoy sport you know get out
there stay active find something that
you enjoy
find your passions do a lot of different
things because you might be like me
you might find yourself not watching the
olympics in 2021
and then find yourself in the olympic
final four years later so you just never
know enjoy sport enjoy
staying active and uh and make sure you
keep supporting the
the olympians by sending them lots of
messages through the social media
channels
that's amazing steve thank you so much
for your time i think everyone out there
can learn a lot from
your journey through especially sort of
how flexible you've been in
in realizing the opportunities you have
at your disposal and also just
enjoying sport like you said all the way
through your life it's such a huge part
of australian culture
stay thanks again for your time and hope
you guys have all enjoyed our little
chat have a good one
thanks eddie